[Music]
so morning everyone
thanks for coming here 11 o'clock in the
morning today it's a great turnout we
are gonna have a really hopefully a lot
of fun the next hour and a half we've
got an incredible group of four people
here to lead this discussion on neuro
prosthetics so without further ado our
first guest is professor of biomedical
engineering and radiology and director
of the ultrasound and elasticity imaging
lab at Columbia here in New York she's
written over a hundred and forty
articles serves as an associate editor
in I Triple E transactions and
ultrasonics she focuses on the
development of novel imaging techniques
for elasticity and using therapeutic
ultrasound to access and treat the brain
please welcome Alisa Cano fabu our next
participant is associate professor with
the center of neural science here at NYU
he's pioneered the study of how
populations of neurons communicate to
guide behavior
he's also invented a novel brain machine
interface that uses the activity of
small groups of neurons to decode
intentions and other cognitive processes
he's been awarded a Sloan research
fellowship the McKnight Scholar Award
and the National Science Foundation
Career Award
please welcome Bijan pesarattu
also joining us this morning is a
neuroscientist and neural engineer and a
Lange endowed chair in physiology at the
University of California San Francisco
his research focuses on how the brain
uses sensory feedback to maintain
accurate and adaptive movement control
and his lab applies this research to the
development of brain machine interfaces
together with two members of his lab he
was awarded the 2013 annual brain
computer interface research award for
his work on the development of
artificial somatosensory feedback please
welcome Phillips avis and our final
participant is an assistant professor in
the Institute for computational medicine
in the department of biomedical
engineering at Johns Hopkins University
she was a postdoctoral fellow previously
in brain and cognitive sciences at MIT
her research attempts to understand
neuronal patterns in the central nervous
system in both health and various
diseases she uses computational modeling
techniques to model neuronal behaviors
and our applications that span a number
of disorders of the human brain
including Parkinson's disease epilepsy
brain machine interfaces pain and even
sleep please welcome
Sri Sri Sarma so we're gonna first show
a brief video of a patient who has had a
deep brain stimulation implant these are
things that probably a lot of people
have seen on YouTube before or on
television and so if we could show that
first video please let me know so this
is actually a patient of mine that we
implanted a system and this is this is
so this is Blair Ford my neurologist I
work with talking in the background this
patient has essential tremor it's a
disorder of the cerebellum where you can
see cannot control his movement
particularly when he tries in action
becomes incredibly disabling he can't
drink from a cup he can't write so
there's we turned off says oh boy
because he gets a
sensory jolt when it happens can you
take this finger touch my finger and
then touch your nose go back and forth a
few times and so you can see this is
really life-changing innovations with
essential tremor
Parkinson's disease things like this but
also this is interesting to note this
system was implanted a decade ago so
what we're doing now technically is very
similar to what we were doing a decade
ago what we're gonna really focus on
this morning is where do we go from here
how do we how do we advance from here
still a little and if we could now show
the next video just talking a little bit
about what deep brain stimulation
actually is and then we can use that as
a lead-in to talk about deep brain
stimulation as opposed to
neuroprosthetics which is really our
focus this morning so three good yeah so
what you see here is invasive implant
you go through a surgery you get leads
electrodes implanted into a target
region of your brain you see something
that looks like a pacemaker
that's called a neuro stimulator there's
a voltage controlled current source
sends current through those leaves that
are sitting under the skin so you can't
see it and it activates a volume of
tissue in the vicinity of the tip of the
electrode so the idea of deep brain
stimulation is you know the the brain
basically communicates through
electrical activity if the neural
patterns the electrical patterns in the
brain that govern our behaviors so when
you're changing the electrical patterns
with deep brain stimulation the hope is
you change behavior for the better so if
somebody has disease like a movement
disorder like Parkinson's which resting
tremor rigidity brady kinesia the idea
is to activate the right part of the
brain at the right time with the right
signal to suppress those symptoms so
that's sort of the principle behind the
therapy so in clinical neuroscience we
refer to that as neuromodulation we're
modulating an existing system of the
brain and somebody who has a disease
that's causing that system to not work
as well but that's not really a
neuroprosthetic so Phillip maybe heat
also bill a bit about what because it's
not a subtle difference what is a neuro
prosthetic sure so when you think about
modulation basically what you're talking
about is a circuit that's sort of off
kilter it's out of back it's oscillating
at the wrong frequencies or it's sending
the wrong patterns and what you want to
do is somehow try to move it back into
the right operating regime if you will
when we talk about a prosthetic device
generally usually what we were thinking
about is replacing something something
that's missing something that's broken
restoring function replacing a part a
prosthetic heart right putting in a new
heart and so on and so when you think
about a neural prosthetic what we
usually think about is replacing lost
function and there are many examples of
neural prosthetics the earliest one of
course is the is the cochlear implant to
replace hearing for those whose cochlea
aren't working right and now there are
also fda-approved and in Europe
proofread and longer retinal implants
that do the same sort of thing that
stimulate tissue in the periphery in the
eye or in the ear in order to replace
vision or audition but these days sort
of the new frontier really is thinking
about
brain implants so these are implants
that would go into the brain that would
replace lost function and there are a
number of examples of that
the one that's probably furthest along
is a motor prosthetic so this is for
people say for example who have spinal
cord injury or who have ALS Lou Gehrig's
disease who are paralyzed and can't move
their bodies and then what you could do
is you can put a set of electrodes say
in in motor cortex which is the part of
the brain on the superficial part of the
brain up here that normally activates in
order to control limb or muscles lower
limb upper limb the rest of our body and
you can read out activity from those
neurons and use that to infer what it is
that the patient wanted to do and then
use a machine or a computer to control
some external device that would replace
function so that could be a robotic limb
it could be a computer interface like a
cursor and it could be a wheelchair
could be you may have seen recently in
the news there were some news about
stimulating muscles so it could even be
functional electrical stimulation of the
muscle to reanimate the patient's own
limb and so when I talk about a motor
prosthesis that's usually what what we
think about
so as you're saying it motor prosthesis
development has been around for a while
you know people for all
ten years have shown pictures of of the
ability to move a mechanical or a
robotic arm so there's a lot of
development beyond that so maybe people
could take a little chance and turn to
oven Bichon talk a little bit about the
importance of multiple areas of the
brain and integrating those areas to
build an effective prosthesis so you
know the brains of a complex network
it's got a tremendous number of
connections that link you know widely
diverse groups of neurons and there are
a lot of disorders of brain activity
which depend on that communication being
intact and even a motor prosthetic is a
readout prosthetic you're taking a
signal of intent I want to move like
this and translating it into sum over
movement by some other device you're
tapping into the circuit and pulling the
signals out but I think that it's
important to recognize in people or do
sort of tackle this problem in fact what
some of the flips recent work is
directly related to this which is that
even when you're reading something out
from the brain there's a lot of activity
within other networks within the brain
that are a critical to the construction
of the rib the signal that you read out
so even something as a sort of overt as
a movement has a lot of internal
consequences so how does the robotic arm
feel where is the robotic arm right now
is it's ready to move like this exactly
when you want to move as opposed to when
you're acting moving in the future so
planning as opposed to execution other
cognitive thoughts like decision-making
like how does the robotic arm know when
you're thinking about making decision to
move in advance of moving and those
components of the activity in the brain
are really important to doing a good job
of reading out something something that
seems a simple perhaps as a motor
readout and then you start getting into
those more higher cognitive functions
you start thinking about replacing all
of them so somebody who is unable to
maintain a memory of a certain type or
is unable to speak or communicate
clearly right so you could think of all
kinds of other of mental functions which
give rise to those abilities that you
would then be able to repair potentially
with or even treat and cure ultimately
with some kind of a brain interface that
works across
did networks so shri talk to us a little
bit about the importance of being able
to model neural networks as we think
about building devices for humans right
so I mean in the context of neural
prosthetics I mean what are we trying to
do we're trying to replace restore some
kind of neural function but
neuroscientists I mean spend their lives
trying to understand what is that
function for a very small part of the
brain so you know if you go to the
Society for Neuroscience meetings which
whether it's 30,000 people each are
focused on one small subsystem of a
system and so forth and they are the
expert there but it's very hard to
understand not only what did that little
subsystem doing but who's talking to
that system
who is that system then talking to and
then really understand how the neurons
are communicating what are they
communicating how are they communicating
about external stimuli about your body
your behavior and so forth so there's a
there's intelligence in these kinds of
neural prosthetics and that I mean
besides the barriers of can you put
something into the brain that's going to
not have a you know rapid immunise mewn
response that's gonna make it you know
obsolete or just dysfunctional and so
forth the first thing you need to do one
of the things you need to do is
understand well what are you going to
replace it with right if there is a
brain region that's been damaged you're
gonna put something in there to replace
it what's its function and how do you
code that that's what neuroscientists
basically live and breathe is to
understand brain function so modeling is
a good way to come about trying to
answer these kinds of questions so
there's what is modeling modeling is
basically describing
how neurons fire action potentials and
communicate those X potentials to their
neighbors through equations through
mathematical equations differential
equations through that are generated
sometimes through biophysical laws
sometimes you just gather you know you
collect data and you build statistical
models but what those models are trying
to do is to associate some kind of
environmental stimuli to how those
neurons are firing so that once you know
that Association that's when you start
understanding what it's doing and what
its function is and then you can start
thinking about replacing it with
algorithms and
on a chip basically so so most of the
work that's been in the popular press
and things to date has been mostly about
uni-directional devices so being able to
harness the movement system and move an
artificial limb and all of you are
talking about taking all this knowledge
and making it bi-directional integrating
what the brain does naturally so maybe
we can dive into that a little deeper
and thought maybe you could start off
and talk about the importance of the
sensory feedback in building a device
excellent ok so I think there's a video
we have that I'd like you to look at so
we're talking about patients with spinal
cord injury or ALS so clearly there's
something that this is not a patient who
looks normal or intact so can anybody
out there guess I mean I know a short
video with a little line Mickey Mouse
over at the top of it but can anyone
guess what was wrong with this person
any guesses good guess
lost function that is like maybe spinal
cord injury maybe stroke any other
guesses coordination in general maybe
some kind of cerebellar deficit or
something actually this person's motor
system is totally fine there's nothing
wrong with it
the problem is what's it exactly he's
lost his somatosensory feedback so this
shows you that here's somebody who's
motorically fine but whose ability to
feel his own body is impaired and it
looks like he has a motor deficit so we
know that loop that motor feed that
sensory feedback is critical in order to
be able to execute proper motor control
ok so when you look at the current state
of a motor neural prosthetics there have
been some tremendous demonstrations of
human patients moving robotic limbs
getting pretty good control of cursors
to operate say an iPad or something like
that and that's really great but the
level of control that you see from those
devices is still quite far from what you
would exploit you'd hope to see in terms
of natural behavior it doesn't look
naturalistic it's still slow it's still
a bird a lot like the kinds of movements
that we saw there and so my lab was
thinking that what we really needed was
to restore the sense of proprioception
and their number of labs working on this
problem and it's a tricky problem for
the reason remember I talked before
about cochlear implants and retinal
prosthesis and they work really well
because there's what we call a
typography which is to say that nearby
neurons encode similar things and
there's a map so if you look at the
cochlea for example two nice spiral
shape and as you move along the spiral
you change frequency of the tone that
you hear so if you stimulate here you
might hear a 1k of one kilohertz tone
and if you stimulate here you might hear
a 5 kilohertz tone and that's a nice map
that allows you to create sets of tones
that you know the person will hear and
will make sense but in some areas of the
brain and actually in many areas the
brain certainly the kinds of areas that
vision was talking about related to
higher cognition we don't have that kind
of topography and unfortunately that's
even true for proprioceptive feedback
for this ability when I say
proprioception what I mean is this
ability to know where your body is the
kind of things that allows me to do this
or this with my eyes closed because I
can feel where my body is and there's no
good simple map in the brain for that so
when we stimulate we're going to excite
neurons that maybe encode this direction
and this direction and this direction
and we don't know what the person will
feel that's a problem and so here we
rely on the kinds of models that Suri
was just talking about we had been
thinking about this problem of how it is
that you know where your body is and how
you combine information and we had built
some models earlier showing that the
brain in principle could quite readily
learn to incorporate new signals brand
new signals that never experienced
before as long as those signals
correlated moment by moment with things
that it did know in other words that two
signals were telling it about the same
thing that was really just theoretical
work done by Joe Macon and Matt fellows
and Ben dictor in my lab and then Maria
da de lot and I said well maybe we could
use this to develop a new approach to
prosthetics so we train a monkey to do
this is just kind of a proof-of-concept
experiment I'm going to show you we
train a monkey to do kind of a strange
task which I think there's a video for
where a monkey was asked to reach to
make reaching movements and what you can
see there is this is what the monkey saw
and that little small circle is a cursor
that represents where the monkeys hand
was on a table so his job was just to
move from one target to the next and
what you can see is you can't actually
see where
targets are instead what he sees is a
bunch of dots moving along the screen
and he knows that if the dots are moving
down into the left for example the
targets get me down to the left and then
if he overshoots that the dots change
direction so it's this kind of weird
online feedback of of what he's supposed
to be doing and the reason we set this
up this way is it allowed us to create a
case where the we have an intact monkey
so it's not sort of really a neural
prosthetic application he's moving his
limb but there's a sensory signal that
without it he can't do the task and
that's knowing where the target is
relative to where he is right now so we
train him to do this test but this kind
of weird visual signal signal and then
what we did in the next video is that we
started combining that visual signal
that he'd been trained to use with
something totally novel so what you're
gonna see is on the on the left there
this is just the same as what we saw
before but on the right there are eight
lines of little green ticks and each of
those little green ticks is a is a
precise little moment of stimulation
a little pulse of current that we put
into the brain that excited a couple of
maybe ten or hundred neurons nearby each
individual electrode we had eight
electrodes and each electrode was
arbitrarily assigned a direction so for
example in this case the monkey had to
move up and to the right and so the the
electrodes that correspond to up until
the right that has those little red
arrows up and to the right are the ones
that are pulsing the highest and the
other ones are pulsing the lowest and
when the monkey first felt this it
probably just felt like some weird
tickling on his arm it didn't mean
anything to him
but what we're doing here isn't trying
to recreate natural patterns of activity
like you would do in the cochlea but
instead what we're trying to do is
harness natural modes of learning in the
brain and the idea is that is that when
the brain sees two things that correlate
that are telling it the same thing it
can't help but integrate and so it's
seeing the vision that it knows and it's
getting this weird pattern of
stimulation that it doesn't and when we
first start stimulating actually his
performance with those green ticks with
that stimulation is worse than when he
just can see the visual cue but within a
day or so it's about the same and over
the next days and weeks the performance
starts getting better and better and
better when he can see those green ticks
with vision compared to what he can't
until ultimately what you just saw in
that video was there's no visual cue at
all
he's sitting in the dark and he knows
what to do because he can feel where the
target is from that set of stimulating
electrodes so the point of this
experiment was that we can write
information into the brain that the
brain doesn't know anything about but
we're harnessing the natural modes of
activity which is that the brain is
always looking for correlations looking
to combine things that it can make sense
of and in this case using vision and
this artificial stimulation and we think
that this is readily adaptable to the
problem of providing proprioception to a
real BMI and that's work that's going on
in lab right now led by John O Doherty a
postdoc in my lab so the training effect
is really important that's right
training's christa if you walk to gum
while texting and going down the subway
stairs over time you'll get better of
all and you'll annoy a lot of people in
the process
Bijan so your thoughts on on making
things bi-directional and harnessing the
brain's needs
well so what flipper hasn't shown yet
but I'm pretty positive you're working
on this is looking at the activity in
the brain simultaneously to the time
when he's stimulating right and so that
is technically complicated but not
impossible at all and then what would be
interesting to think about is how you
could alter how he's stimulating based
on the measured changes in the brain
activity he's recording either at the
same location or perhaps even in other
locations and so now what you're
starting to do is is you know bridge the
network effectively and an altar this is
the critical concept altering how you
feed signals into the brain instead of
being blind to the activity in the brain
saying the activity the brain is almost
maybe what I would like it to be to
allow someone to perceive the feeling of
movement in a certain way but it would
be better if I were to stimulate less
perhaps or in a more precise way and so
combining the recordings with the
simulation specifically at different
points in the brain is is I think really
important to making naturalistic
performance and then extending to these
other cases so but all of these
approaches they require recording the
brain invasively so 3 how much can we
advanced modeling without actually
having to go
to the brain so I mean there are people
who who have looked at non-invasive
techniques and for neural prosthetics I
just want to make one point and it's
related to this in response to what flip
has said about the you know harnessing
the natural learning mechanisms that are
already in the brain there are heated
debates within the scientific community
and BMI to say you know they're the
modelers who are really trying to
understand the details of what the
neurons are doing what should be the
optimal pattern to get the best behavior
that I need and let me try to put that
into the brain if it something's damaged
versus other people saying you don't
need to do that the brain will rewire
and figure it out just give put the put
implant in create a very simple mapping
a computer algorithm that's trying to
map the neural activity that you're
feeding out to some kind of control of a
device and even if its course and not
right and not really what the neurons
are doing but neurons will figure out
how to use that device to create the
desired behavior so you don't need to do
all your fancy math and models the brain
will rewire and do it themselves so we
go through these heated heated debate on
that but in terms of non-invasive I mean
it really depends on what your objective
is if you're just trying to save you're
in a wheelchair and you just want to
learn how to control the wheelchair with
just natural thoughts or maybe that if
the person cannot control the wheelchair
themself but they want to move around
you could even take something like scalp
EEG people have demonstrated this where
you just put a cap on and they and you
map the signals coming from the scalp
EEG into some computer the computer
interprets fat and Society okay move the
chill wheelchair up or down turn to the
right or turn to the left something very
simple like that it's already been done
so you know so it depends on what you're
trying to achieve if you're trying to
achieve you know fine control of you
know 23 degrees of freedoms of your
fingers and your wrists and so forth and
you want to feel things it's not clear
to me today that we can do that
non-invasive way so let's switch Jack's
a little bit down so you've been working
on using ultrasound as a way to access
the brain without having to go in
the brain so talk to us a little about
the concepts of that how you do it what
you can learn from it where we can apply
it yes it's something very core
intuitive so using out for sound to
either stimulate the brain or change the
blood-brain barrier to have take drugs
so it's something that it's not as
intuitive as electrical to electrical so
you put an electrode in the brain and
then you can stimulate the brain or
modulated by having fire action
potentials so in this case we actually
use mechanical perturbations and it
turns out that just as the brain is
capable of adjusting the electrical side
of the stimulation we also can do this
mechanically so the brain is actually
posting at every heartbeat its app
taking oxygen but the blood vessel so it
knows what to do with mechanical
perturbation so in the ultrasound case
we can focus through the skull so that's
something that has come about over the
past decade so we figured out the
technology through intact scalp or skull
so we actually penetrate through the
skin and we can focus within a few
millimeters in the brain and we can
change that so what you see the video
there is actually the white region
that's oscillating is the ultrasound
beam we also can this is the blood
vessel red and you can see the tight
junctions that are oscillating these are
the look like bricks on the lining the
endothelial walls and they open up and
what you can see also is the neuron on
the on the left side that's up taking
the drug now as the which is in purple
and reaching finally the neuron that you
want to to treat in this case that will
be for treatment of Alzheimer's disease
or Parkinson's disease or ALS so trying
to reverse this this diseases by
modulating in this case the blood vessel
the actual vasculature - to relax and
become more permeable because our brain
is very much very well shielded when it
comes to treatment to drugs and which is
great when you have a normal brain when
we have a pathological brain it's
actually a very huge bottleneck to
actually treat it so without this micro
bubbles that you saw the
we can actually also stimulate the
neurons and this is something that has
been coming about over the past five
years or so and we now can go into
subcortical regions in the subthalamic
nucleus or hippocampus and focus
mechanical waves ultrasound waves in
this region only safely and we're able
to actually get very very localized
perturbations of the brain and and that
converts to action potentials and what
we hope to do is also map the circuitry
completely non-invasive it's and now
when you took take the electrodes and
you actually go you know one region by
region you need you know thousands of
electrodes to do that so potentially we
could also go accordingly subcortical ii
the good thing about ultrasound is that
you can actually penetrate over several
centimeters very similar to what you do
in imaging so these are the advantages
that Allison can can offer complementary
to what happens in the in the theatrical
side so the thought would be to use
pulses of ultrasound to stimulate
activity or inhibit areas of the brain
to get the results you want exactly yes
do we have any idea how ultrasound is
actually working to do this well we
don't have we have an idea we don't know
exactly the mechanism so there's
definitely the ion channels that are
involved so we have channels on the
membranes of the neurons that are
actually releasing calcium or potassium
of sodium so that turns out that can be
modulated throughout the sound but it
has that's a theory that some people
have actually done with models and it
does check out but we have to go to the
to the brain and and figure that out
it's not easy obviously because you can
also do this on a petri dish but it
doesn't necessarily translate to in vivo
which the network's are so much more
complex and also the other thing is that
we all we we think there's also a net
force that from the propagation of the
wave the net force in the entire brain
and that alters the stretch aspect ratio
of the neurons and we know that when you
do that if you take neurons on a matrix
and you stretch it they're gonna start
firing action potentials so both of them
may be happening at the same time the
ion channels may be regulated
through these mechanical forces and then
we can in either a hibbett or excite the
neurons that way so say we figure out
exactly how this all works and then we
want to couple it into a neural
prosthesis so how much can you
miniaturize it how much can you make it
applicable to people in everyday life
we're actually working on that so there
are distance users that we that send out
for sound waves and also receive them so
obviously in this case we want to send
waves you can make them as thin as a
sheet of paper it turns out there they
are materials where you can have these
Spears or composites which are peers or
electric so that means that you have an
electric potential that's fired across
the crystal that you use and then that
mechanically vibrates at the ultrasound
frequency that you need it to so you
don't have to have very clunky big
transducers you can actually make them
as thin as a patch so the idea is
actually to put that on the on the
Scarlets on the scalp itself and have
some wiring but in this case is actually
all external and have that you know
having having that post at the frequency
that you want for example the essential
tremor to be treated or in the case of
the blood-brain barrier have it opened
when the drug is actually administered
IV so you can have that also replaced if
it causes any you know infection on the
skin for example but we can go we can
miniaturize that you know pretty pretty
pretty nicely and you know - very very
sane and also the skull has the
curvature that allows it to be serving
as an acoustic lens so it's a concave so
when you have the sheet on the concave
part of the of the skull it actually
focuses as well in the region so you can
utilize that as well and and does the
brain attenuate its response over time
if you keep hitting with ultrasound does
it keep working so that's a question
that we have to answer but we expect it
to be very similar to electrical
stimulation so as long as you know
damaging the region you can also damage
that region if you have to there is a
group at the University of Virginia who
does
essential tremor ablation that take the
array in that case envy MRI and the pin
and the perform a very small lesion on
the order of a millimeter in the in the
middle of the brain and stop the
essential tremors within 20 minutes and
is very very efficient so if you wanted
to cause permanent you know inhibitory
activity you can do that but you can
also do this at lower levels lower
intensity levels when you don't cause
any permanent damage and you can
repeatedly have the same effect so we
talked a lot about how to harness the
brain signal and take advantage of the
different aspects to it
Bishan you've done work trying to think
about how do we develop a better and end
product to then translate through so
talk about some of the issues about so
once you understand proprioception in
the brain and the different areas
feeding in how do we develop a
prosthesis that can take advantage of
that information so I think that one of
the major issues is that the
non-invasive approach is the one which
has the greatest market it's the one
that's gonna benefit anybody basically
who's willing to use the device it's not
dangerous in any meaningful sense but
it's also very limited in its scope I
think this is generally true and in
contrast if you go into the brain and
you get access to all of the relevant
neurons you're gonna be able to replace
almost any function to bring this
capable of but that's highly invasive
and so that's not very practical and
certainly not safe in many cases or even
possible in many ways so how do you
bridge the fact that the technology
doesn't necessarily work so well or very
effective it's not that effective but
brightly it broadly applicable but it is
probably applicable in one situation
non-invasive situation and then when you
want to actually you know achieve the
sort of the promise of everything that
you could imagine being possible it's
just not practical and so this is a huge
issue because I think it's holding back
the field effectively because either
it's impossible or it's not necessarily
so what I want to be studying or what I
want to be able to give other people and
so the point is there's another way and
so the other way that we've been
exploring is looking across the
different scales so I think was really
critical to
think about is you know the size of the
brain
our brains are you know about 1.4
kilograms there may be you know this big
and they contain elements which are
neurons which are about that say 10
microns so 10 millionths of a meter in
size so you can see a neuron as you can
see something that's 10 microns in size
with a microscope that's not that
powerful
you can see you know the group of
neurons together 80 microns is like the
width of a human hair you can definitely
see that with a regular you know unaided
eye and so the brain is made up of
billions of these small elements that
comprise a 1.4 kilograms hole and so the
point is that if you're looking at a
centimeter scale or a millimeter scale
you're looking the surface for example I
have force I'm actually I'm not familiar
with the latest in this area how
precisely can you manipulate neural
activity non-invasively at a certain
location yeah any general location a lot
of specific one but in general let's say
I don't know what the answer is let's
call it five millimeters yes it's a be
me a meter a millimeter okay so within
that millimeter though there are going
to be thousands and thousands of neurons
and those neurons have different
connections and they have different jobs
to do perhaps and if you could but still
millimeters pretty good if you could get
access to every millimeter separately
within the brain that's a pretty
powerful device that's definitely
controlling millions of voxels and how
well that can work as a big question and
so we don't know who's ever done and I
don't believe this has been done in an
EVO behaving situation something like
the person but I think that thinking
about how well you could do with a
millimeter instead of a centimeter which
is typically the resolution of
non-invasive electrical devices so a
non-invasive electrical devices aug
system or a brain stimulator of some
sort that's on the scalp if there's a
lot of excitement about these you can go
look at neuro hacking on YouTube and see
some pretty crazy stories the people
will tell of stimulating with currents
with batteries on the surface of their
brain so that's definitely down at the
centimeter scale basically and then you
want to get down to microns which is
what sterile scientist will tell you
definitely going to answer the question
if you're down in love
Micron's but an engineer would say well
do I need to be down at the level of
microns this is the big question and we
do not know what the answer is and I
think that it's clear that there's a
better way than going a centimeter which
doesn't work necessarily for everybody
and do much of interest or going all the
way down to microns which is optically
accessible you can do this but this is
pretty invasive
totally invasive at this point and
what's in between and I think that
thinking about optimizing interfaces and
functionalities of devices for
particular cases at the millimeter scale
or my favorite to be honest I think you
can replace everything down probably
down to like 100 or 200 microns and
think you need to be down at the
cellular level but that's debatable
and maybe millimeters just as good if I
could follow up on that so I think bees
are laid out the problem quite well
there's a there's a big debate about
this you know in the field right now is
to sort of the scale of operation and
and and how fine of a parcel ation we
need to be able to understand and
manipulate circuits there's no doubt
that we can do neuromodulation with
electrodes that are huge the DBS
electrodes are you know - it's a - yes -
millimeter diameter so these are really
big devices if compared to the scales
that vision was just talking about yeah
when you look at sort of the cutting
edge of modern neuroscience in parsing
out circuits what you see is people who
are using optical techniques to look at
the cellular scale and showing the
individual neurons have cell types cell
type is kind of a very common theme that
a word of a buzz word that you hear all
the time now in the field meaning that
different cells belong to different
classes and those classes seemed are
different functions and if you
manipulate one specific cell type you
might have a very different effect on a
circuit than if you can manipulate
another cell type and when you think
about treatment so from a scientific
perspective you know the Holy Grail
would be to be able to manipulate at
that cellular resolution across large
circuits that spend millimeters or
centimeters that's a very tall order of
course from a clinical perspective the
question is how much of that resolution
is needed and I think that these are
still very much open questions it
probably is the case
that if you could manipulate a certain
cell type at a say 100 micron or
millimeter resolution that's kind of
effective 10 there that you might
potentially have more power than if you
could just sort of stimulate all the
cells in a local region and there are a
variety of techniques that people are
thinking about for this the most obvious
one that comes to mind for people in the
field is optogenetics which is the
ability to use light to open specific
ion channels that were engineered so so
you put these new ion channels using
genetic techniques into specific classes
of neurons or into neurons generally and
when you shine light they open which
causes either a neuron to activate or
neuron to silence and that kind of
resolution this is now opto genetics is
a is a huge field that's taken over in
many ways is one of the cutting edge
tools of neuroscience it's pervasive so
that's the kind of thing that is making
its way slowly into the clinic now I
think and there are other techniques
people looking at ways to do similar
sorts of things with with electrical
stimulation and there may be other ways
say for example not by targeting
necessarily using the cellular
physiology to target particular cell
types but some of the things that for
example be John is looking at where you
can look at connectivity between two
brain areas and target the cells the
projections here say for example of the
cells there which is a kind of
specificity but also might offer us a
lot of power so these are kind of all on
the frontier both scientifically and a
little bit further on clinically
carefully but just a quick thing since
we have I think some students in the
audience I mean the technologies are
there to basically image small whole
brains right we can see activity of
thousands of neurons across structures
lots and lots of data is collected and
in certain labs data are collected all
the time and now today we're in a
situation where how do we deal with this
big neuro data the typical
neuroscientist is not trained to deal
with big data right these big data
scientists you know they'd learn machine
learning optimization all kind of
pattern recognition techniques they're
good at that but they don't know
anything about the neurobiology and the
nerves
and that you've got the neuroscientists
or performing these experiments so I
think the next generation I think what
universities are trying to do our build
training programs to train you guys to
be interdisciplinary and to be able to
then understand to be John's point what
is it this single neuron how does it
impact the emergent behavior of the
organism how do you cross all those
scales and then we'll be able to stare
to figure out okay if I want this
behavior I don't need to be at this
resolution I can manipulate up here okay
and so we still need to understand how
things dynamics across the scales and I
think where the data is there that the
the the you know basically the knowledge
of how to glean that information and
model that is still for the next
generation I think to come in resolved
so that brings up an issue though
because as Bijan was saying we've got a
big brain and so we're trying to think
about learning really specifically where
an area is it's important for a certain
task that we want to build a prosthesis
for so so there's a conflict there
because we've got all this real estate
and we're trying to find a very small
area perhaps so how do we do that this
is I would even question that premise in
many cases I think that the localization
paradigm is very influential and
important and there are clearly
functions in maps that can be localized
to locations on those maps but I think
that those functions are for the most
part fairly basic or well described
through an interface to the external
world and the more abstract interpretive
functions of the brain which underlie
our cognitive abilities are probably not
localized to locations and that perhaps
there are functions which can be
manipulated by doing a fairly precise
knockout or enhancement because the
network will respond in a way which will
you know leads to the change that we're
talking about that so be more precise
there could be a complicated network
that's responsible for your ability to
remember your childhood but many
different parts of the brain many
neurons are involved in this ability to
recall your memories but you may be able
to disrupt that by knocking out a
particular part of the network for
example and maybe even restore it by
maybe replacing that very small piece
but that may be a specific case of a
function where the network itself is
supporting the function but your
intervention is having an effect by
finding that special piece it's like the
magic bullet in the brain targeting
domain but there may not be magic
bullets for a range of things and I
think that the localization dogma is
coming into question because it's not
being as effective as it is it maybe
should be and I think that the critical
point that you basically can ignore this
is almost certainly true is that
different brains our brains are all very
different from each other every brain is
basically a butterfly and so the
challenge of finding that magic spa that
you need to innovate interface with to
replace a complex disorder even if it
does exist in each brain you need to
find it in each brain and there's a lot
of clinical trials which are targeting
you know complex cognitive functions
like depression mood
obsessive-compulsive disorder all the
rest of it with this localized spot
manipulating paradigm and they look
great before they spend a hundred
million dollars to do the clinical trial
but when they pick the random subset of
people whose brains they haven't mapped
fully and then try to intervene it
doesn't work so well cuz I don't know
where to go so I think there's an
inherent tension here there are
functions which could be localized and
the way you treat the mr. to diagnose it
by finding that spot and then going
through that localize the plot to treat
it or there could be other functions
which are actually not localizable and
you can't actually control the network
from a from a point and really what
you're gonna have to do is come up with
a more descriptive broader distributed
description and so this is I think is
this is all basic science debates but it
has very practical implications for the
development of technology so how do we
study this how do we tatah we take the
steps forward because like you say
everybody in the room is an individual
and so how do you how do you all as a
there's a group envision studying
humanity
in a way where we leverage big data and
the variability between brains to say
whether or not there's a sweet spot is
there an endogenous rhythm that we
should be tapping into how do you see
going forward to take it to the next
step well I think that I guess I would
say that it depends on the problem
you're trying to solve so for some
problems I do actually think that
relying on learning as Surrey and I were
talking about earlier is probably the
way to go in other words if you're
trying to provide artificial
proprioception it probably would be
better
you'd get faster learning and maybe even
ultimately a little better performance
if you could tap into just the right
parts of the brain with sort of the best
approximation to the natural code that
you could but if you get close enough in
terms of the location of the brain it'll
probably be almost as good and you could
probably stimulate almost anywhere and a
person could learn to use that feedback
for control just like we learn to use
all kinds of strange artificial feedback
to drive our movements in video games or
in driving a car or something like that
and so I think that that's a case where
it while while there may be fine
localization we can probably get away
with approximation to that but there are
other problems where I think that this
sort of drive to individualization is
going to have to be the answer and you
know I think there are a couple of
examples of that
there have been studies for example this
is just to give you an idea of the
problem in visual cortex where you can
ask if I'm looking at a neuron right
here in visual cortex that might
represent you know some little part of
my visual field and some set of features
of the visual world or something like
that and ask who does it connect to this
cell you might think well connects to
its neighbors strongly and then it's its
next-door neighbors a little bit less
and so on down the line
but actually what you see is is there's
a patchy connectivity and the
connectivity probably makes some sense
based on the maps about orientation
other things but it's patchy and you
can't predict in advance exactly what
that connectivity pattern is going to be
and I think that kind of patchiness of
the brain where there are these very
small groups of cells that might be like
micro columns is the term that people
use in cortex or live just little
collections of cells in other brain
areas might be working
together functionally but they're hard
to find this gets to the kind of thing
that vision was talking about and you
know when you look at say for example
the clinical trials for depression which
haven't worked as well as one would have
hoped from the preliminary data but they
do work in some subjects very well
patients very well as as we were talking
about earlier before he came on stage
why is that and one possibility might be
well you know they're just some subjects
that are amenable to that form of
neuromodulation and some that aren't and
that's a possibility but another
possibility is exactly this problem
trying to find just those little micro
domains that are the right ones for that
patient and what do you do about that I
think it may be that non-invasive
pre-surgical imaging will get to the
point that it's good enough that you can
find those domains and that's one of the
things that me Jean is using extensively
and trying to map out connectivity
between brain areas in advance of
surgical procedures and actually we have
a procedure on Monday using some of the
same techniques that vision is using in
one of our animals but another technique
I think is to develop neural interfaces
that are very flexible so to be able to
safely put in thousands of electrodes
even though you know you don't need
thousands but you put in thousands
because it's safe and it's easy to do
and then you can individualize the
treatment after the fact because you've
got a bandwidth to do that and that's an
approach that I think a number of people
are thinking about as a way to go and
it's something that we're actively
working on in my lab and engineering my
lab ten Hanson who's a very talented
engineer working with some engineers at
Berkeley to develop a scheme where we
can put two three thousand very fine
flexible electrodes into a monkey brain
in the first instance of course actually
rat brain in the first instance but the
goal is to be able to put in so many
that we can try to find those micro
domains after the fact so what's the
spatial constraint there those two three
thousand electrodes are going over what
what area great well what we're trying
to do is to make it that you can
individualize it so you can put you can
put them as close as you want up to say
maybe on the order of 50 to 100 microns
close to each other so that's to think
about Bichons description before that's
maybe about five cell width apart or ten
cell width apart that's on one end or
because each one can be put anywhere you
if you wanted you could put them with a
great deal of less density but across
dozens of brain areas we think that's a
an interesting space to work in that
hasn't been very well explored yet I
think the concept here if I could
emphasize it is this is a standard in
the you know the treatment paradigm is
diagnosis first and then treatment right
this is always how this works every
doctor has to diagnose disorder before
they can properly treat it and that this
plays a very important critical role in
brain you know treatments with devices
is that the diagnosis phase itself needs
a special divine my mind needs and I
think people already the people are
doing this needs a special device which
will deal with this variability problem
that sure you could have a non-invasive
stage first of course because the
diagnosis device itself isn't going
everywhere but it is going more places
than you need for treatment and it will
then basically build a model of this
brain that's functioning in a certain
way that we want to you know understand
and deal with and then we will diagnose
this person's brain and then system not
the whole thing but the functional
system that we care about and then we
will will either turn off a bunch of the
implant functionality to reduce its
power load and heat and whatever or we
will do a secondary surgical procedure
where we pull out this monster device so
to speak and then replace it with the
targeted device which may be even and
and small endoscopically delivered maybe
through the the vascular system because
you get a lot of access to the brain
through the vasculature and then you
could have much less morbid outcome and
yet still have that ultimate goal of
precise and effective diagnosis is
important to obviously have you know the
imaging across scales so we have you
know vga fMRI we have MRI diffusion
tensor imaging and you know other
techniques that can be complementary at
different scales which it would be
optical techniques or you know more on
the electrical side those you have to
basically probably go with with the
treatment itself because diagnostically
right now we need more techniques that
can go to cellular level but
fortunately the physics catches up with
us especially in imaging where you know
you want to have a resolution of 10
microns but unfortunately that cannot
happen over several centimeters so if a
brain was as small as a mouse brain then
we could do the optical thing makes that
people do or remove the skull completely
and then do the egg gnostics and basic
science unfortunately we know more about
the rodent brain and we know about the
primate brain except for what happens
and in monkeys but it's it's we have
this this trade-off between resolution
and penetration nothing and we can't
really beat the physics but we can
probably go across scales and combine or
everything that we do here but you have
to have the new generation likes we said
of students which are going to be
talking know these languages across
scales because optical techniques are
great for microns electro techniques are
also great for microns and then as you
go higher we know magnetic acoustic even
chemical techniques or even you know
more in the nuclear side those are
higher scales so you have to understand
didn't understand the brain you have to
understand across scales and that's
gonna take a lot so you guys are talking
about the ability to put you know a
thousand electrodes in a relatively
small space and sample and see what's
best sure you talked about machine
learning and big datasets and in the
experiment that you showed Philip you
know it took a while it took a while for
that for that to work how can we use
machine learning to speed up the process
so that we have an implant how can we
use computer learning to do what we want
the patient to do that might take six
months so we can ramp it up and basic
like you said before take advantage of
the brain's own hardware and chemistry
to let the brain learn itself rather
than having to put humans through tasks
every day right
well machine learning it's the it's
basically the field of you know if you
have a large data set about some
underlying phenomena or process you know
how can you just take all that big data
and uncover sort of the structure in it
and the structure can be much sparser
than the data you have and typically the
data is noisy it's messy there's missing
data and so forth so what machine
learning is all about is how do you
develop techniques and algorithms
that are gonna find that underlying
structure that's much sparser than the
data itself that's going to teach you
something about the process so it's kind
of a high level description of machine
learning so when it comes to big neuro
data you can imagine we are seeing
firing patterns of activities of whether
it's individual cells or populations of
cells and so forth all of that activity
is big data it's it's crosses time space
and so forth so it's complex data it's
noisy there's variability because you're
getting this from multiple brains and so
forth so the idea there is okay you know
maybe I collected this data under some
kind of behavior maybe when the animal
is was making a choice to you know pick
this pellet versus that pellet what
happened in the brain who's talking to
who who's really sort of necessary to
derive you know to drive that behavior
and create the allow the animal to make
the right choice
well machine learning would go in there
and say okay I'm going to from all of
this time series data across space and
time I'm gonna try to figure out exactly
what sort of the fundamental network
underlying and governing this behavior
it's going to be just a handful of
necessary structures and then how does
those structures talk to each other and
communicate to ultimately generate the
pattern of activity that's gonna make
that animal make the right choice right
so it's trying to uncover sparse
structure from very dense data and
that's what machine learning does but
with that said I don't know if you guys
are thinking as when flippin being on
we're going back and forth and talking
about the sort of the ideal of placing
thousands of electrodes all in the brain
so we can you know in a non-invasive way
how many of you thought that sounds
completely counter to like an oxymoron
non-invasive moving okay minimally
invasive but I bring this up and I don't
know if guy you can shut me down if you
don't want to go there but DBS as you
saw in the animation that's two
electrodes going in the brain okay and
it can be remarkable in terms of a
therapy how many actually get it so what
would you rather do pop a pill or get
thousands of electrodes minimally
invasively going into your brain and I
think this is going to be once we figure
it all out it's going to be an issue of
how are you gonna you know have the
population accept this there I mean I
think that's a great thing let's return
it in one second still if had a comment
on the data and I think you can
absolutely return to it so I just want
to say one thing about about machine
learning which is that if you look at
the state of the art of motor neural
prosthetics many groups that are
involved in this are are using what what
you could think of as Co adaptive
procedures in other words we've talked a
lot about how people will adapt to the
device but the device is at the same
time using ideas from statistics and
machine learning
adapting to what the person is doing or
the monkey is doing and that's that's
another way that machine learning can
help so it's not like you you you buy a
machine you hook it up to your brain and
you need to learn to use it like a car
it's more like something that's
constantly trying to understand what
you're doing and refit to you so I think
actually it's a really good idea to
return to that because you know a very
small percentage of Parkinson's patients
actually get deep brain stimulation
surgery a very small percentage of
essential tremor patients because
there's a fear factor and there's a real
risk I mean surgery has risk and sorry I
actually keep a set of scales in my
office because every surgical decision
is risk-benefit you know you want it to
be like that and so it brings up the
issue of not just how do we make it safe
but also what conditions are appropriate
so I mean at the beginning Phillip you
talked about there's certain things that
are obvious so a motor prosthesis for an
amputee somebody who's who's you know
who's lost a limb in a war you know that
that's an obvious to think about for
somebody or somebody who has spinal cord
injury or ALS Lou Gehrig's disease you
know things like that you know but when
you're talking the risk-benefit we've
got to make it incredibly safe we've got
to make sure that the early populations
were studying have an incredibly low
complication rate we've got to make sure
that we're picking the right populations
of people and the right targeting
techniques because if you're wrong early
on and it costs a hundred million
dollars to run a trial and it fails then
it's going to be really are
to go forward these are huge issues so
why don't Akal some of those so what do
you guys think about as you start
pushing it a little bit what conditions
enter your mind as appropriate to think
about for neuroprosthetics so let me
just say one thing before we get into
this debate which is that we're very
fortunate to be in a situation where
we've got many layers of legal
regulation on what we do and so it's not
as if one of us or even a surgeon can
just decide you know be really cool
would be to take this person who's got
blank and stick 100 electrodes in and
see what happened that's just not how it
works there are many layers you have to
convince the what's called the IRB the
internal review board at your own
institution you have to convince the
federal there the Food and Drug
Administration in the federal government
you have to commit a funding agency to
pay for it and they'll look at the
scientific merit of these studies and so
on and so we're in an environment where
you know it's fun to discuss these
things and we should discuss them early
on but I just want the audience to
realize that it's not like we get to
make these decisions in an environment
like this this is a there's a lot of due
process that goes into these phenomena
so I can continue or I can let someone
else take you I would just want to say
because we didn't talk about the
non-invasive stimulation other than
outer sound which is basically TMS
transcranial magnetic stimulation or in
ECT electroconvulsive therapy so these
are actually used outside the brain and
we still don't know how exactly it works
sometimes it really works wonderfully
and and people are really treated you
know especially for depression and it
has outstanding effects but other times
you know there's no effects at all and
we still have to go back to the basics
understanding how stimulation really
works and we still you know so basic to
clinical he has to be a feedback
mechanism constant going back to the
basic understanding with stimulation
does and and then going back and re
tweaking and I think the DBS is is
actually one of the things that works
very well but it is invasive and it will
be nice to actually be able to make it
more amenable to patients and when it
works and we can learn from DBS
then apply it also to non-invasive or
minimally invasive procedures but I
think the loop needs to be constantly
closed and with there's a lot of basics
that we still don't understand so that
we can and we need a lot of advancements
in every aspect of technology right so I
mean that DBS system grew out of
pacemaker technology it's 20 year old
technology we're still using it right
and so we need to understand what we're
treating how we're treating and then we
need to advance the field of what to
actually treat with right now 20 year
old technology might sound like a bad
thing and if you're gonna go buy a new
car you wouldn't buy a 20 year old car
so why are you putting a 20 year old DBS
in your head um but there's a good
reason for it because the the risk
factor of it as well to be low because
it's been put in so many patients we
have a good feeling for what for what
the risks are and so I think when you go
forward you think about this
cost-benefit analysis the risk benefit
analysis that you were talking about
that of course changes over time right
now you know you talked about motor
disorders you could you severe
depression other kind of severe
psychological debilitating psychological
disorders are the sorts of things that
we're where the alternative to
intractable conditions like these where
drugs aren't working from for example
the alternative is a great deal of
suffering then it makes a lot of sense
to think about opening the head and
putting in what may be a novel or
relatively experimental device so that's
the gain and then what's the cost well
the cost is that every time you open the
head there's a risk if you put in a
device that you know isn't going to last
more than five to ten years that's an
inherent risk right there and the
current devices that we have not the DBS
devices they may last a little bit
longer but the kinds of more advanced
devices that we're talking about for
stimulation and recording don't have
terribly long lifespans at the moment so
that I think will automatically limit
where we're going but I'm actually a
little bit I have to admit somewhat
bullish on this I I think that as the
technology gets better as we get smaller
devices that can be implanted with
smaller holes in the cranium for example
as we get devices that become wireless
and that can be wholly implanted in the
head with lower power and so on as we
get devices that can stay in the tissue
and function for ideally 20 30 40 years
the people will see that risk coming
down and as they become more widely
accepted more people
have an implant in their head it won't
seem like such a strange and foreign and
odd thing that the the scope of
conditions that clinicians patients and
the regulatory agencies start thinking
about as plausible and reasonable
alternatives will grow and I think that
that's going to happen soon I think on
the you know 15 20 year time frame
you're gonna see a great expansion of
the kinds of conditions that people will
be getting their head opened to have
implants put into tree but this is I
just wanted to just bring out the point
the this is a very personal choice
that's even is made even in the cases
when it's clinically indicated so
forgetting about all kinds of other
decisions people make about themselves
and so in the military for example they
are you know developing a lot of
advanced technologies over the years for
prosthetic prostheses and what was
interesting about their experience this
is nothing to do with the brain
necessarily this is just you know some
kind of external robotic robotic system
and maybe controlled by the muscles or
may be controlled by movements of your
body in other ways and as opposed so the
simplest prosthesis you could get is
that you know it's the hook right you
just mount it onto somebody's eyes of an
amputee they've lost some part of their
arm you can mount the hook onto their
arm and they can use it through some
kind of pulley and spring system to
manipulate it to talk to to hook things
with their hook this is a very
established prosthesis technology their
more advanced versions which allow the
hook to have a hand with 20-some degrees
of freedom or even interface then with
the muscles and then you you imagine
clenching a muscle and then signals or
your compression muscle and the signals
go into the now robotic hand and then
move the hand so these things basically
exist and they're available for people
who you know unfortunately need them and
what's interesting about this is that
there are basically very different user
adoption scenarios that some people will
have this implant that are mounted on to
the many van implants in many cases
they're mounted onto
stumped let's say and use it very well
and never use it again and other people
who have the same clinical condition
will have it mounted on their arm
they'll use it exactly the same way the
other person uses it and will use it all
the time and so what divides people into
these kinds of groups and why is it you
get rejection and adoption when you
would think that it's all about how long
does it last and how you know how
difficult you know these people using it
the same way they're reporting the same
user experience in a sense it doesn't
hurt it's functional to the same level
of dexterity that they could be scored
on with some tests of performance and
yet there's a totally different decision
underlying the use and so this is true
in all technologies right so some people
can't stand smartphones because they'd
much rather have buttons on there you
know there's all kinds of issues where
this is played out in the same basic way
so I think that it's I need like any
advanced technology people are gonna
have a very personal relationship to it
and this is gonna more than I think
anything else ultimately govern this
discussion is it do you want to use it
but just back to your original you know
all the hurdles to get through the
process getting a clinical trial to be
more likely to succeed and I'm not
saying that's because to give myself
purpose but I think this is where
mathematical modeling can play a huge
role in the future which is the idea of
virtual clinical trials what is a
virtual clinical trial well if you could
model the phenomena the system that
you're trying to to change with a drug
or with the electrical stimulation if
you can model that you can use
predictions from the model to say yeah
these are the group of people that are
going to respond to this very well but
these will not and and this this could
prevent a lot of failures going down
board I think the barrier there is the
culture of the FDA and and then Society
of just accepting mathematical modeling
as you know just believing in it that
they can make these predictions and
showing that they play a big role in the
communal in the pipeline going from you
know idea to clinical trial to actually
getting FDA approved and out then you
deal with the adoption issue but I
actually think that modeling plays a
role in adoption as well maybe not so
much for the layperson but for the
physician at least
where if after the fact you have a model
and you really understand the mechanism
and you can show that with that model
you can predict maybe how specific sub
population will respond or if you tweak
the thing in this way this will change
in this way even if that model doesn't
allow you to improve therapy what it
does is it gives the scientists
confidence that they understand why it's
working they can convey that to
clinicians and they can sit they can tap
they can look they're patient the eye
and say we understand how this works and
I think that can help with adoption as
well so let's push the limits a little
I'm going to give you a hypothetical so
we've got a device that we know we've
figured out how to work the motor system
it's working great now we've figured out
where a a nodal region is that can that
can work on memory and we've got an MRI
system and a genetic test and sequencing
together that can tell you if you have a
family history that you're going to get
Alzheimer's and it's going to start when
you're 60
so you're 59 you know your memory is
going to start going away next year is
it appropriate to think about a neural
prosthesis be for that person who's
going to turn 60 development to help
protect their memory or as long as you
possibly can from the effects of
Alzheimer's would that how do you guys
think about that
but then but then if you can fix you can
enhance and then the young kids will say
well wait you know why can't I get that
neuroprosthetic and I'll have enhanced
memory and I'll do really well in school
and I'll do all kinds of issues I'm
about will you know I think the border
between treatment and Han sment is an
interesting one so here's an example
imagine that you that you have an
implant what these exist for vision okay
so what that means right is that I can't
see and so you're gonna give me
something where I'm gonna a little
camera say mounted on my glasses it's
gonna look around the world and it's
gonna allow me to see what's around me
that makes a lot of sense and that's
restoration of function right make sense
but next thing well hold on what I
really want to do in the evenings I want
to read okay now what I could do is I
could look at my Kindle but that
introduces a lot of noise wouldn't it be
better to just have my iPhone talk to
the device
and put the text directly in now surely
that's a good idea that you should do
that right I think that makes sense I
don't think anyone who might have a
problem with a blind person being able
to read directly from their iPhone okay
but if you can do that then does that
mean that I can also use it as a general
interface for browsing the web it still
makes sense right but then the next
person says oh wait wait I can I can
have my brain talk directly to my iPhone
I want one too and and you know this is
a it's a it's a very you know where
where does that border come and I think
this is where again all these layers of
you know it's not as if I can go buy one
at Walgreens and put it in myself right
these are not going to ever be
over-the-counter treatments and so you
know I think that you know we have lots
of examples of treatments where you know
look at in fetta means as a treatment
for ADHD in children right that's a it's
a real disorder and it really helps lots
of children and there are lots of people
who'd like to get their hands on them
and you know sometimes that happens and
bad things can happen but on the balance
we've got a system for dealing with that
and in some ways the risk here is less
because it's not like you can get your
buddy to give you his brain implant at
school that's not gonna work I think we
have to develop technologies that we can
prevent you know Alzheimer's or diagnose
it early because genetic testing for
example you know black up one bracket -
for breast cancer you know it's only 5%
of the patients so the side that you
have you know the mutation doesn't
necessarily you know have you have a no
time clock that works always on
stochastic probability-wise so then you
have the early diagnosis is very key and
I think we taught me better a few ticks
here but I think the diagnosis is
understanding you know early onset or
even preventing the disease down the
line I think these are actually more
important you know from the point of
view of treatment because you know how
do you wanna treat Alzheimer's that's
the other option so you have detected it
you know how you're gonna add a good
stage that you start you start early
these are made late so your enhancement
question reminds me of the you know the
surgical joke where patient comes in the
office and says well doctor will I be
able to play the piano well after
surgery and you say of course you oh
we're not gonna hurt you pianos go
that's great cuz I couldn't blame
you know we could actually talk all day
about this but I think it'd be really
you know we've brought up a lot of
topics here and I'm sure some people in
the room have questions for some of our
speakers about any aspect related to
things we've covered or potentially
something that we haven't covered so
anyone from the room questions in the
back over there yeah hold on one second
so we can get a mic to you okay so
everyone can hear your question hello uh
so I won't computer science and grad
student actually and I have this
question because since it came out I'm
more interested in learning about the
non localized nature of neurons and how
they communicate in general from your
perspective and how does
neuroprosthetics deal with that I mean
just to give you an idea I think of it
like a community on Facebook now just
because I have other neighbors to me for
localized we might not be as well
connected but when you have someone else
maybe on the other side of the world I
might be more intimately connected
through some other connection you know
like maybe a Harry Potter or something
like that right so does the same happen
in the brain and if so how do you guys
deal with it so I mean this is the kind
of thing that we study in my lab and we
actually had a paper recently where we
found that if you just take a group of
neurons that you've recorded blindly
let's say from part of the brain or a
couple of parts of the brain and then
what you do is you label them according
to how well they're working in terms of
their firing patterns with other
activity in another part of the brain
and so what you can do is you can label
them as being sort of communicative not
communicative in a sense and then what
you can do is for asking questions about
these now labeled neurons in terms of
how well do they predict decisions so
the subjects you know all these neurons
are actually producing the decisions
that the subjects making at some point
in the future perfectly well so you can
predict exactly what this person's going
to do later on 100% no errors but it
takes longer to listen and figure out
what's going to be done in the future if
you are analyzing only the
non-communicative neurons and if instead
you analyze the communicative neurons
you can get that information much faster
and so there already is evidence
suggesting the
whay you might want to read things out
is conditioned on these network
properties there's a big challenge
though in that in what is communicate to
mean what's the definition that was you
brought up that people are connected and
they're both love Harry Potter versus
this person lives next door to you
that's a spacial proximity where you
could draw a graph and that could be or
it could be so so what does it mean to
be connected and there's in neuroscience
we have notions of structural
connectivity at this neuron physically
projects to the other neuron therefore
it must talk to that neuron versus these
neurons are firing while these neurons
are firing during this path they're
functionally connected so I think these
are challenges that we still face and so
yeah yeah so the whole point was what is
our definition of communication is a
huge issue and it's be clear this is not
an atomic connectivity because I think
what's really important to recognize
about the operation of these circuits is
they're totally dynamic like they are
not staying still for more than a few
hundred milliseconds of most and they're
constantly updating and shifting around
every minute every hour - every day -
every time you fall asleep you dream you
wake up so nothing is that stable and so
an Anatomy is pretty stable on this
scale it's certainly not that stable
either neurons grow send out connections
and die so they also change their
anatomical properties but I think that
absolutely this idea of communication is
not anatomical its functional and it's
highly dynamic and debatable exactly
what it is but I think that if you can
show that a group of neurons that you're
labeling is communicative and then
you're predicting what they're saying
better then you've got some meaningful
definition of communication so you're
saying we can all take confidence in the
fact that we're fundamentally unstable
other question yeah over here
hello very interesting stuff there
interesting stuff you might put on
prosthesis yeah I know I'm wondering you
guys are talking about a lot of
restorative functions which is extremely
interesting and very applicable but I'm
kind of wondering once you start delving
into that sort of field how you might
start to kind of coax out some more
super human abilities certain aspects
where you might rewire the brain or just
I want to quit smoking I want to lose
weight whatever and those kind of
patterns that emerge in your brain that
stopped you from doing that how much
might you be able to restore them beyond
that how you might even be able to do
certain things that are sci-fi
essentially just beyond the immediate
application that we have today and the
needs to fix your arm doing this and now
you can use it properly and whatever so
I'm kind of wondering if you guys can
talk upon that's super humanity well let
me start with the examples smoking
because I think that's a good one where
there's a transient need hopefully or
any addiction really and you know what
what about that and that's a case where
I think something like ultrasound or you
could and that's I think that may be on
the horizon being able to treat
transient disorders with non-invasive
brain manipulation obviously we do that
already with drugs but to do it with
circuit manipulation like this I think
is around the corner and is a great idea
and again it gets to this this
cost-benefit ratio what if you know once
we understood the addiction better you
realized that we could do it with
stimulation but it's going to require a
massive implant with lots of electrodes
maybe then no you know then you know
nicotine gum is probably a great way to
go so it depends on the Bennett the
cost-benefit ratio and I think with
enhancement again you know I'm gonna
kind of just say what I a little bit
more when I said before which is that I
think that although there's no doubt
that one could start thinking that way
and although
elements of what might look like
enhancement will probably be part of the
therapies that we use there will always
be there
strict legal and ethical framework at
least in the United States that that
runs the show and that we all have to
work in and and for now that's true and
and I think that it would preclude
things like getting an implant simply
because I want to be stronger than my
neighbor but that's implants right if
it's non-invasive so right Lisa
continues to yeah on her SATs well path
then how do you prevent girls from
getting not I mean if your kids get some
memory enhancement and they're taking
the same test my kids are I want that
memory enhancement to have it
Silicon Valley that's using to tDCS
which is putting dry erase batteries
basically taking an eyeball to try to
get athletes to be able to jump higher I
mean literally that's what they're doing
and you know right now it's not I take
the very Brighton but I I'm gonna come
back I come back to this myself all the
tight it is a very personal thing and I
think that in ways that are not always
obvious so for example let's say that
you want to enhance yourself okay and
you think there's some problem in a test
you can't solve whatever right so you're
gonna go ahead and enhance yourself what
you're gonna do is you're gonna change
in your brain somehow that's like the
first order statement otherwise
nothing's gonna happen
the second order statement then is now
your brain is gonna adapt and the brain
doesn't know exactly what it is you're
trying to do to it because it's got its
own insight in a sense mind and so it is
responding to your intervention which
you're only like sort of secondarily
aware of like your conscious awareness
is not a lot of what's going on inside
your brain and so then what you have to
deal with is the fact that maybe it's
not working very well and you're not she
doing better on the test so the first
thing with all of these implants is that
it makes it worse rather than makes it
better so then what you have to do is go
oh well I'm gonna stop using this this
is the whole adoption thing I'm gonna
stop using this because I don't like you
very much or I'm gonna try harder and
then what you have to deal with is
improving your interface and using it
more and changing it more and then you
basically become very married to your
technology and I think we're all aware
of this in our personal lives because we
have advanced technologies at our
disposal and I think the basic rule
about all of these things is you never
use it less
and you always basically use it more and
so I think where this goes is full-blown
cyber reality and this is a choice that
ends up because these things don't work
that well on their own it's the whole
point all technology right is it my
personal philosophy havior but all
technology leads to some side effects
which then need more technology to fix
and I think that this is just how it
works and sure you could get an amazing
technology that doesn't require any
alteration to anything else I would like
to see a list of those technologies I
mean for everybody in the room with kids
try to take your cell phone away from
your kid at bedtime right and we all
fight that question in the back
do you think one I wondered what of the
technologies ultrasounded starts are
that your deep brain simulation what are
the next practical areas where we're
gonna see these technologies coming into
the clinic and and that and the second
question was just around the interface
between digital technologies and farm
and pharmacologic technologies you know
because even in terms of you know we're
you know we now have convection delivery
of G DNF for Parkinson's disease to the
putamen etc so I wondered about the the
way in which drugs will have a
potentially a different kind of
interface or use in conjunction with
with these and as well in terms of
digital technologies I'll log you know
Adam gazali and kind of a way in which
you can scope neural circuits digitally
so it's a lot of questions but this is a
big issue and I mean obviously we talk
about devices a lot here but there's
also the other world and we alluded to
that the drugs and there's also another
word with world which is basically the
combination of the two and that world is
very atrophic and not much has been down
there why because you have the drug you
know people who are actually experts
there who don't understand devices and
devices basically we don't necessarily
understand drugs so there needs to be
another area where the two worked
together and in fact in the brain
we have to make it work because
conventional hands for example that he
is using do DNF for Parkinson's that's
also you know very invasive it doesn't
always work we don't understand why this
injections I go deep in the brain
110 actually work there's a lot of the
brain is not actually designed to take
up drugs through injection so there's a
lot of engineering of how you do that
part so it's important to actually cross
over to the drug world as well and and
have devices like you know the ones that
we discussed and enhance the those drugs
but not only the existent drugs but we
can actually design drugs now that can
can be used optimally in combination
with devices and that's something that's
a world that's completely bare right now
I think it's a new new frontier and it
will need a lot of efforts to bridge
that and on the order it's also in order
of difficulty at the FDA because the FDA
is also not structured necessarily like
this you have also device versus drug
there is also the combination of the two
but it's it's very also not very well
developed so I think that's a big big
challenge but I think in the brain we'll
have to solve that challenge because we
can help the brain from all sides and we
need to use on the the drug front with a
device front together very wisely so I
think it's a great question and when you
think about treatment of any kind of
brain disorder you think about exactly
what you said
drugs rehabilitation or training and and
some kind of circuit stimulation based
mechanism and in fact there's one
example that's combining those three to
great effect right now in spinal cord
injury are there groups in Southern
California and in Switzerland we've had
remarkable success with this and they
don't really understand the mechanism I
should tell you but remarkable success
with this three pronged approach
altogether so what they're doing they're
doing this in rodent and they're doing
it in human patients is they're using a
cocktail of drugs that seems to put the
spinal cord of brain and the spinal cord
into a more plastic state number one
number two they're stimulating and
they're stimulating to try to in effect
to try to use plastic mechanisms in the
brain that would normally be there to
dry
reconnection of spinal pathways while
the animal or the person is going
through the motion saying a treadmill of
movement so there's a little bit of
rehab because they're getting the real
motion to happen
there's stimulation and there's drugs
all together and they find just
empirically now there's no real deep
understanding of the mechanism yet but
when you combine those they get actually
quite remarkable effects that are that
are beyond anything I've seen in terms
of functional restoration in spinal cord
injury so I think you're absolutely
right trying to think about how to merge
diamonds is is great exactly that's
right three ways of driving that that's
right yeah another question in the back
hi thank you for holding this discussion
so I was wondering like I know other
research institutions are also for
example manufacturing micro electrodes
to be really really small and then maybe
uh some other institutions are looking
at which material is going to be the
most biocompatible for these electrodes
so how do you communicate among each
other within each other to say like oh
we actually don't need an electrode this
tiny or oh maybe this material would be
better for like creating the resonating
what's so that we can create the
ultrasound waves so how do you
communicate with these different
research institutions so nobody's well
you minimize the efforts of other you
know each other's efforts so how do you
enhance collaboration and communication
yeah I think it's a it's a little bit at
hoc still we could do better there with
some data some data science part but
yeah so you obviously have to be in
touch with all the papers they're across
different journals I would say about ten
journals you also get your Google Alerts
and all that stuff and also in
conferences you have to go and and
basically have these kind of
conversations and on a regular basis
because it's very difficult you can read
different
a journal article and you understand the
overall concept in the methods but
there's a lot behind it that's actually
never really reported how many times
didn't work actually nobody reports that
and because you won't get published so
you have to basically guess what happens
as you read a paper how many times they
actually did it before I started working
and then you get this it is nice
conversations and the feedback
unfortunately will be nice to have you
know some kind of a database of the
electrodes that don't work in the
specification so the address and that
doesn't work in specific cases as well
but we yeah that's you obsessively ask
people though yes in question that the
thing that they never yeah made totally
public but underlie everything that
basically followed I mean I won't you
just gotta find out what that question
is yeah I mean this whole thing of
collaborations I think the biggest
challenge isn't fundamentally are our
academic funding agency that that system
is flawed so if you really want someone
to say be a neuroscientist and do
experiments and really understand how to
mine that data machine learning and so
forth how do you actually train that
person well that person has to belong to
the experimental slab maybe they're in
flips lab and they flips got some money
to do a project he's gotta get that
experiment done because that's what NIH
is funding him for so why would flip
allow his student or why would he be had
given incentive to him to send his
student off to work with the best
machine learning person in his
university to really spend some time in
that lab when he's paying for that
person and he has to get his stuff done
right because you've got the agencies
kind of so we have these issues here
that you know barriers that you know the
agencies are not giving us incentives to
train that crosser you know disciplinary
students allow them to really understand
the device world versus the experimental
world versus something else and I think
this is some it's a big challenge I'm
gonna just give a little shout out to an
agency that's funded I think everyone on
the on the panel here which is DARPA
that actually is very good at this sort
of thing
DARPA does create teaming DARPA does let
you know when you're on a road that
another person that their funding is on
a similar road and often encourages
investigators to talk to each other and
that's something
that I think the the NIH and the NSF and
other funding agencies don't do as much
it's ultimately it's our responsibility
to go out and find out what other people
are doing but I think it is something
that the agencies could help with yeah
so uh unfortunately we could take
questions actually I'm sure for hours
and hours and maybe some of the speakers
are willing to individually have based
on their schedules but are actually a
lot of time is up so we officially have
to call it here and so I'd really like
to thank everyone for all
[Applause]
[Music]